The Internet of things is an idea that's
been around for uh,
I dunno,
maybe 10,
15 years or so.
And I think the first time I heard about
it,
um,
there was some discussion of a European,
uh,
appliance manufacturer who had a
refrigerator that was connected to the
network,
the,
the Internet.
And,
uh,
I think the,
the scenarios that were playing out
there,
we're okay.
What if the refrigerator was smart and
knew that the new enough to adjust
temperatures,
maybe it new enough to send a request or
a message to the manufacturer saying,
Hey,
the compressor's going bad.
Um,
that was Kinda the first time I had
heard about this idea of connecting a
product to the network,
a product that wasn't a traditional
computer.
It wasn't something that we thought was
supposed to be connected to the network
are interconnected.
And that started to open up,
um,
a lot of people's eyes,
I think to this idea.
Um,
it may not have been the first
theoretical time that it was discussed,
but it was the first time that I think
popular media and culture started
talking about this idea.
But for whatever reason that connected
refrigerator really didn't take off the
idea,
really didn't kind of explode,
I think.
Then we started hearing about the
connected washing machine and the same
kind of context.
And I think that that idea of the
Internet of things then started to
refine a bit.
And we heard about machine to machine
communication,
the idea that instead of human to
machine,
so sort of a through a screen or through
a web page or through our mobile phones
or whatever,
that machines would talk to one another.
And uh,
so the idea of a,
a,
a stock quote generating a message that
would be sent to another machine that
might think about,
okay,
now I made need to make a trade.
So the automated trading world or a
weather forecast that's reported online
triggering a message,
uh,
to another system that's going to adjust
stock levels.
So this idea that machines might talk to
one another without a human in between
was sort of a refinement.
I think of the Internet of things idea.
And now,
uh,
over the last handful of years we're
seeing more consumer facing,
um,
ideas and concepts.
And products coming out that I think of
has regenerated interest in this,
in this machine to machine
communication.
So now we're hearing things about the
connected car and the connected
thermostat and the smart home.
And so now that the,
the consumer side of things is,
is heating up,
we're also asking ourselves from a
business perspective,
what is the Internet of things for a
business maybe where you don't have a
consumer product or a,
a thing,
a widget that you sell,
maybe you're a services company or bank.
What does the Internet of things mean
for a business like that,
particularly a services company.
And so for,
for companies that aren't as a consumer
facing or product oriented,
I think,
you know,
there,
there's more opportunity but more,
um,
sort of clouds around what that,
what the Internet of things means for
business.
And I think that anything that we,
uh,
that we think about that we estimate
that we,
uh,
operate in the places we work in,
people we work with.
Um,
we think about the effectiveness of
those things,
the effectiveness of our workplace,
the effectiveness of a warehouse,
the effectiveness of routes that a truck
takes or that a forklift makes.
Um,
and we make guesses about the right ways
to,
to design a workspace or design a
logistics path,
design and warehouse.
And the question is,
can we use the idea of sensors to
collect data about things that we were
just guessing about?
Before that we were estimating that we
were,
that we were sort of like using our gut
to,
to design.
Can we collect real data about
performance of people and places and
processes that can give us more insight
into optimizing and evolving our designs
for the way our business works.
And that's what I call the Internet of
business things.
It's not the consumer facing stuff,
it's the business stuff.
Most of the data we think about,
uh,
from a,
an enterprise perspective is,
is sort of modular.
It's transactional.
It's,
it's a a call center call or it's a web
transaction or it's a sale or it's a a
quote.
Um,
or it's a piece of data about a product.
but the Internet of things we'll be
creating streams of data.
So one of the analogies is,
is how social media create streams of
data.
So we've got tweets and we've got,
uh,
flows on our,
on our wall and such that are more
streams of information.
And so think about a,
a sensor that might be on a,
on a door and a warehouse.
Every time the door opens,
the sensor records a,
a door opening,
a time of day,
day of week.
Um,
maybe it creates some other ambient
information,
like it records the temperature in the,
in the facility or it records how long
the door was open or whatever.
So these are little bits of data that
are happening every time the door is
open and that door might be open a lot
of times during an hour or a,
or a day or a week or a month.
But it's creating these streams of data
and it's,
it's not like that one piece of data
might be that interesting,
but it's the trends and the patterns and
things that we're looking for in the
data that may be what we're looking for.
So I want to know,
you know,
how often is that room used,
uh,
during the morning,
the afternoon,
certain days of the week,
weeks of the month,
that,
you know,
months of the year to help me be more
efficient about the way I staff people
in that office or,
uh,
the,
the temperature or the cooling or the
electricity that I feed to that part of
my,
uh,
of my facility.
So that data that's created,
these streams of data are,
are sets of data that I may not already
have a,
uh,
a technology platform to process.
I don't know how to process streams.
Maybe.
So now I have to think about a new
architecture,
a new way to process a stream of data,
not just a stream,
but you know,
maybe I have a hundred facilities that I
have the sensors in and they're creating
these streams of data.
So now I've got a a new challenge around
data.
One of the challenges starts to feed and
link into the big data topic.
So as I'm collecting the,
these individual sensor data points over
hundreds or thousands or tens of
thousands of sensors every minute or
every second,
I've now got these,
these,
these parallel streams of data I have to
process.
And so it's unclear exactly how much
data I would want to keep for how long.
But it's certainly a new kind of data
architecture and for some companies will
be a big data problem because there's
going to be a lot of this data for large
companies,
for a lot of sensors and a lot of
facilities or a lot of products that
they want to track or whatever it is
that they want to get more insight into
by putting tags or sensors on them.
So to me this is one of the sort of
subset subdomains of big data around
sensor data streams of data that we're
going to have to think about new
architectures and new designs for a new
technologies,
for capturing them,
storing them,
processing them,
aggregating them,
analyzing them.
And so on.
So I think it's going to be a real
interesting evolution to see how the big
data technologies and and technologies
in general are,
are emerging to deal with streams of,
of sensor data.